[Musik]
Crystal Meth ist Sachsens Volksdroge
tausende Jungs und Mädchen männer und
Frauen sind süchtig Jobs gehören Crystal
und andere Drogen zum Feiern einfach
dazu die Polizei kontrolliert zeigt
harte Hand doch Drogenhändler Dealer
Konsumenten sind oftmals schneller es
ist ein ständiges Katz und
mausspiele er nennt sich born Schweiz
und rappt über die Zeit als er Crystal
Meth konsumiert hat täglich im
Erzgebirge Vokal Gemballa herkommt ist
die Droge leicht zu bekommen ein Kollege
hatte dem damals fast 16-Jährigen
Crystal angeboten und Karl hat's
genommen warum das weiß er noch ganz
genau
einfach nur Langeweile also natürlich
könnte man sagen da diese Probleme haben
wir dazu geführt dass ich überhaupt das
sind die Situation gekommen bin aber es
ist halt auf dem Dorf so du hast nicht
viele Option und
dann gibt's noch die Bierzelte und die
Leute die sich dort weglaufen sind
meistens einfach voll blöd in einem
Keller nimmt er das erste Mal Crystal
Meth ja irgendwie hat man es gar nicht
so richtig registriert also ich fühle
mich persönlich habe natürlich habe ich
gemerkt Alter jetzt passiert was ich bin
total euphorisiert bin
energiegeladen aber
ja es war jetzt nicht so dass ich gesagt
hätte übst krasses Erlebnis oder so
brauche ich jetzt unbedingt noch mal
also
trotzdem macht der weiter und steigert
sich schnell Christel ist einfach immer
verfügbar Karl fliegt von der Schule
lebt ein Leben im Rausch insgesamt zwei
Jahre bis er sich selbst nicht mehr
erkennt er kann nicht mehr in den
Spiegel schauen auf dem das Crystal in
Linien zum Schnupfen liegt man sieht aus
wie Gollum das klingt so total blöd aber
es ist so halt
graues Gesicht eingefallenes Gesicht
oftmals ist auch so dass man gerade in
seinem Rauschzustand dann denkt dass man
überall Pickel hat dann fängt man an
überall rum zu quetschen und dann wird
es läuft das Blau an und es wird halt
eklig also du siehst wirklich verfault
aus sein
muss denkst du nicht nach warum machst
du warum längst du dich da denkst du
wirklich das korrekt was gerade ab geht
in deinem Schädel oder gibst du wirklich
Fick auf alles und auf jeden Fall ich
habe mich halt doch selber nicht
wiedererkannt so ich war davor weil ich
ein sehr sportlicher Mensch und dann
wollte ich mal joggen gehen und habe
mich mal ein Kilometer geschafft ohne
dass ich angefangen habe also
es war nur offenbar
Sachsen ist das Einfallstor für Crystal
Meth hinter der Grenze in Tschechien
wird es tonnenweise chemisch hergestellt
in illegalen drogenküchen über das
Erzgebirge schwappt es in die Großstädte
das grenznahe Chemnitz gilt seit Jahren
als Drogen Hochburg regelmäßig für die
Polizei hier sogenannte
komplex-kontrollen durch fast 100 Beamte
sind heute im Einsatz diese acht
Jugendlichen haben alle einen Grinder
dabei damit zerkleinert man Marihuana
von Crystal war jetzt hier nichts zu
sehen nein hier in der Kontrolle
tatsächlich keine Funde die mit Crystal
zu tun haben aber halt
Cannabis bzw Marihuana
die Zentralhaltestelle im Zentrum von
Chemnitz Hotspot der Drogen und
Beschaffungskriminalität hier wird offen
gedealt die Polizei kennt ihr Klientel
oft sind es die immer gleichen Leute die
bei den Kontrollen auffallen
also wenn wir bei den Jugendlichen
nichts weiter festgestellt haben bzw
wenn es jetzt keine Gründe gibt die mit
auf das nächstgelegene Revier zu nehmen
dann entlassen wir die Person aus der
Maßnahme ich will nicht ausschließen
dass wir die dann durchaus zu spätere
Stunde hier noch mal in der Stadt
treffen
durchaus denkbar dass die jetzt in dem
Moment gerade auf dem Weg sind sich
beispielsweise irgendwo Betäubungsmittel
wieder zu verschaffen ein paar Stunden
später bei dieser 28-Jährigen Frau
finden die Beamten Crystal eine
konsumeinheit im Wert von ca 50 Euro
üblicherweise in einem clip-tütchen
kristalline weiße Substanz so wie wir es
auch durchaus immer wieder mal Auffinden
bei Personenkontrollen kommt das häufig
vor dass sie Crystal finden für die
Einsatzkräfte ist das nichts
Ungewöhnliches im Rahmen von solchen
Kontrollen oder normalen
Personenkontrollen im Rahmen des
Streifendienstes auch Crystal zu finden
die Frau lässt die Kontrolle fast teilen
haben es los über sich ergehen ganz
sicher ist es nicht ihr erster Kontakt
mit der Polizei die aufgefundenen
Betäubungsmittel werden jetzt durch die
Kollegen sichergestellt die werden dann
im Nachgang vernichtet für die
betroffene beziehungsweise Beschuldigte
hier wird das dementsprechend auch in
Ermittlungsverfahren zur Folge haben und
ansonsten wird die Person jetzt hier vor
Ort nach Abschluss der ersten
polizeilichen Maßnahmen auch entlassen
Crystal Meth ist auch eine party-
am Rande von Partys und Festivals baut
das Team des Chemnitzer Vereins
Rauschzustand seinen mobilen Infostand
auf sie sind vor Ort um mit den
Jugendlichen niederschwellig ins
Gespräch zu kommen die ehrenamtlichen
Helfer wissen dass man die Leute nicht
gänzlich von Drogen fernhalten kann sie
setzen daher eher auf Aufklärung dabei
werden die Folgen der Drogen genauso
thematisiert wie die richtige Dosierung
uns geht grundlegend darum dass wir
Aufklärungsarbeit leisten für Menschen
die an Drogen interessiert sind oder
auch schon Drogen konsumieren und
versuchen damit Schäden die mit dem
Gebrauch einhergehen zu reduzieren
weil ich finde man merkt auf jeden Fall
auch Partys und so weiter dass der
Konsum ist halt irgendwie ein Teil von
der Kultur deswegen finde ich das
wichtig dass man da Aufklärung betreibt
Elisabeth sollte hat Angst dass ihr Sohn
an der Schule mit Drogen in Kontakt
kommt sie sucht Anregungen wie man das
Thema am besten mit einem Kind bespricht
nicht hundertprozentig genau ich habe
jetzt mit meinem Sohn direkt gesprochen
dass er eben keinerlei Getränke
Süßigkeiten
oder ähnliches annehmen soll von egal
von wem und er meint die natürlich mit
einer super vernünftig und das ist ja
klar aber weiß nicht wer man dann zum
Beispiel am concordiapark ist oder so in
Chemnitz das geht ja überall um man ist
ja irgendwo irgendwo davor gefeiert die
Helfer von Rauschzustand lehnen einen
noch strikteres Drogenverbot ab weil es
Jugendliche wieder in private Räume
treiben würde Menschen machen sowieso
und das hat sich ja genau auch in dieser
politischen Führung gezeigt dass die
Bilder die wir von Crystal Meth
konstruiert haben in unserer
Gesellschaft dass die nicht dazu geführt
haben dass Menschen aufgehört haben zu
konsumieren die haben sich nicht
abschrecken lassen die konsumieren
trotzdem
und das heißt wir müssen den Hebel ganz
anders ansetzen
aufklären informieren
auch die konsumierten endkriminalisieren
Uwe wiecher arbeitet seit über 20 Jahren
mit Drogenabhängigen zusammen er glaubt
nicht dass Aufklärung versucht schützt
stellen sich vor Sie wären aufgeklärt
über die Wirkungsweise für das
knollenblätterpilzes und wüssten alles
über die Vergiftungserscheinungen und
wir wirkt glauben sie dass sie dann
Knollenblätterpilze verspeisen können
ohne sich zu vergiften das wird nicht
funktionieren und bei den Drogen ist es
ja auch so nicht nur bei Christel der
ausgebildete Sozialarbeiter schätzt das
Risiko als sehr hoch ein sehr schnell
von Crystal Meth abhängig zu werden jede
Droge ist gefährlich wenn sie auf den
richtigen Menschen trifft also man geht
davon aus dass es Menschen gibt die für
Drogen erstmal sind also die gefährdeter
sind
weil sie ein gewisse Art und Weise von
wirkungserwartung an die Droge stellen
weil sie gewisse Themen haben die die
Droge vermeintlich löst
in der ländlichen Abgeschiedenheit des
Erzgebirges unweit von Chemnitz bietet
Uwe wiecher in seiner Klinik Drogen
entwöhnungstherapien an ab 16 Jahren
immer 24 Wochen am Stück Arbeit auf dem
Bauernhof soll den Klienten helfen
wieder zurück in ein normales Leben ohne
Drogen zu finden
also noch mal auf die Reset-Taste
drücken und zu sagen wie stehe ich denn
in der Welt wie gehe ich mit den
Problemen die mir das Leben stellt um
wie gehe ich mit Enttäuschungen um wie
gehe ich mit Erfolg um Studien zeigen
circa ein Drittel der Klienten von
drogentherapien bleibt clean ein Drittel
wird rückfällig ein Drittel ist
irgendwas dazwischen
doch da die grüne Wiese Karl der Rapper
aus Chemnitz ist inzwischen weg von
Crystal Meth ohne Therapie sondern mit
einem eigenen starken will
ich habe aber wirklich auch mich
abgeschottet ich glaube ich habe ein
viertel Jahr oder so habe ich wirklich
nur zu Hause gehangen größtenteils ganz
viel gekifft suchtverlagerungen
hab übermäßig viele sehr hingeschaut und
ja habe eigentlich nichts gemacht und
das was größte Problem für mich war war
dass ich diese Glücksgefühle die
natürlich auf Konsum so sind die sind
dann halt nicht mehr vorhanden und das
über einen extrem langen Zeitraum also
man ist in einem Tal und ist im Grunde
genommen
karl ist froh dass sein Leben genau so
verlaufen ist mit allen Höhen mit allen
Tiefen mit allen Partys die er gefeiert
hat zum Schluss will er noch einen Satz
loswerden
das glaube ich würde ich jeden mit auf
den Weg geben seinen egozentrisches
Weltbild da ein bisschen zu verlassen
und zu sagen hey ich habe auch eine
Verantwortung gegenüber den Menschen um
mich herum und das sollte schon
Motivation genug sein zu sagen das
reicht jetzt
schon mit 14 Jahren so für meine fresse
0,54,90 ich kann vergessen denn das
nüchtern sein gefällt mir nicht gib den
Schnaps und plötzlich dreht sich diese
Welt um mich lass sie Thema kurz darauf
schon ist Gymnasium verwiesen später
kannst dich auch die Zimmer Fliesen was
für Abbruch meiner Party Chipmunks ist
und ich denke mir dafür sie doch da die
Grünen